I kind of made the bad decision to like
half lay down
so I played myself hey I'm a and I'm
about to stay up for 24 hours straight
[Music]
if someone told me I would stay up for
24 hours I think my instinct would be
horrible idea I up because I was gonna
go to sleep early and then it ended up
being to him and I was on tick tock and
I looked at my phone and I was like okay
I've stayed up pretty long for school
but never just for fun I feel like I'm
dying I think the hardest part is going
to be just finding things to fill the
night with and this is acknowledging
good for me I'm really trying to see if
all my friends are gonna be sleeping
there's only so much Netflix I can binge
right now I'm feeling okay like I'm the
awake scale of like 1 to 10 I'm probably
at like a 6 so I'm definitely already
feeling like I need a coffee which is a
red flag because it's um hour one we
spend many years in our lives sleeping
and what people don't realize is that
what happens at night really affects
what happens during the day
[Music]
I think so okay all righty okay it's
fine
okay so we just got done filming
I'm literally get on route to get my
first cup of coffee our one down thank
you my students what do I think about
taking caffeine and stimulants that's
the right word when we talk about how
much caffeine you should take you know
actually the FDA has a recommended
amount so when people think that that
nine cups of coffee is gonna make him
super alert no that's wrong my third cup
of coffee how do you guys feel do you
think I can do it
you pass out like driving anywhere in
college state of all the time that's
where I'm at so I feel like I'm fine
stay on youtube and watch playlists of
BTS dance practices that's what I do
okay my spirits solid okay this is like
the worst day of my life
the Sun is officially setting over West
Hollywood so it's almost nighttime and
we're feeling good just speaking about
the baseline first just after a normal
work day most of us come home and we're
a little pooped you know I can't say we
have excessive sleepiness we want to hit
the bed right away want to kind of you
know turn the engine off put it in
neutral and just sit down and relax
I don't know what well when I check in
feeling a little bit tired it's gonna be
a night for sure take them into the vise
dance practice watch party I this is my
life now it's 2:30 so we have everything
we have a lot of hours to go still
I'm getting very tired so after 3 a.m.
as you are approaching the sunrise I
think it's gonna be really painful
they're gonna show signs of what I call
hyper Samuel ins mean that that
sleepiness is kicking in it's three I
was really like about to fall asleep so
I decided I needed to get up and do
something and also I realize I'm wearing
this sweatshirt that literally says I'm
so tired and like mood and I decided I'm
gonna clean my room because it's a
disaster before honestly not living
staying awake but loving my room right
now like look at this transformation I
was gonna say something about having a
midnight snack and they realize
absolutely for him for 22 to be exact
we're having is that yeah super now
known to be eating peppers and them as
it like 4:00 in the morning 18
I am and I think I'm dying
I think there'd be troopers in the
beginning saying I can do this this
isn't as bad you know I think I could do
more staying up it's gonna be a delusion
they can do it but they won't realize
that maybe they're starting to not be as
accurate maybe they're starting to you
know get a little eye strain but they
won't feel it right away what's wrong
it's very wrong kind of nice being like
the only person awake and just like
having all this time we're like nobodies
anyway so immediately I couldn't really
scroll anymore because everything he's
asleep it's officially 30 which means I
have been up for 24 hours now I honestly
feel okay which is really weird and kind
of warming yeah I just made this
breakfast quinoa has apples berries
quinoa Simon sugar normally I would
never make a breakfast like this for
myself but it's a time this morning I
did and it's really nice so that's
another Pro
desperate times desperate measures
what we're doing I ended up having six
coffees here a Red Bull at happy hour
and those three clovers a disgusting
amount of caffeine but now I'm here and
I did it when you're asleep the pride my
analogy is always a blood-alcohol limit
think about this in California its point
oh eight if you are sleep-deprived
almost one full night that's like having
a blood-alcohol level of 0.1 spend 24
hours I'm awake but like really barely
at this point I think I did like I said
1 to 10 scale yesterday I said I was
like a 6 I got in the awake scale of
like 1 to 10 I'm probably at like a 6
I'm definitely like a solid like 1.5
right now right above asleep I feel like
I'm gonna cry so when you're
sleep-deprived it definitely affects
your memory your recall your accuracy
your precision and just you'll start
second-guessing yourself quite a lot
[Music]
see I feel like I can't do this no
matter how awake I am oh wait wait
I think is that it that all has to do
string actually looks harder than it
didn't before it was like way nicer
before ah got it
[Music]
I have the worst memory okay I wrote one
but I know I can picture it but I don't
think this is what this animal is called
but I do wait for it
I'm ready I remember armadillo I thought
too long with armadillo name and then I
picked up and I like as soon as I like
stop focusing really hard when I was
like oh what's the name of that animal I
just lost the rest so
[Music]
no I do not feel like I have you bound
but I think it will be my best right now
compared to tomorrow so it was shot so
what's up everyone how's it going oh hey
my ankles starting to hurt but it's not
a bouncing it's just I only have weak
ink okay nope that's it tapped out I got
too cocky
alright let's do this alright so now I
need balance on one foot and I already
like fell over trying to just bend down
earlier so this would be interesting I
think are you ready with the timer yeah
this is working hard there ain't much
less confident no I got it there you go
okay honestly I thought I would be out
by now but this is really good we got
like they'd be honest it's pretty good
[Music]
okay that's respectable I feel like all
right so yeah like I said least artistic
person in the world we're gonna have
colored pencils because Carlos seemed
not sophisticated enough so if we're
gonna start with like a nice little out
okay that's really orange oh yeah nice
shoulders there you go
that's that's what's happening there
okay yeah a nice luscious hair so we're
just kind of outlining everything right
now we're gonna go in with some detail
after because I am a professional
well artists really just do this home
this is
he's like that looks like that I think
so if you want to Commission me for
something I'm open to it so this is the
final product this is me I'm her and I
think it's really good I think it's
beautiful solid work yeah all right
second self-portrait I wore an easier
shirt today so I didn't have to put as
much detail and much as fun as I had
yesterday I just don't have that energy
today so and we're going straight
crayons because okay all righty okay
it's fine
okay I think I like doing it I can't
talk I don't know what to say cuz I'm
just my mind is not here
oh yeah nice hood action that looks like
a nice luscious
[Music]
perfection isn't everything you know
then Oh facial features yeah it's a
little outside in but it's okay okay you
can't color in my shirt and then I'm
done
that's okay thanks fine okay
tada just like a pillow me thank you
yeah I've been thinking about my bed and
sleeping for hours and outside you
really can't wait to go back especially
since I'd like to make it all nice and
it looks like it's like a little
commercial and seen it all back he's
already asleep really good dream very
excited
[Music]
you